partito lui e faccio vedere questi
ragazzi è benvenuta questo nuovo video
sono pari j
ed oggi sono qui con degli del tuo nome
allora ragazzi siamo oggi 4 che ha
gentilmente deciso di affiancarmi in
questo video grazie a poco ti prego ti
devo dire una cosa
il signor warner bros che quello che fai
film giochi belli a un regalo per me che
però se vuoi te lo do ok va bene quindi
oggi cosa facciamo scattiamo dei regali
sei contento si è se me li tengo io mai
ti piace sì ma cos'è leggi lo guarda non
era l'unica scatola regalo questo vuole
niente ciak si vuole aprire il secondo
regalo lo abbiamo secondo facendo un
altro è un'altra scatola il leggo dai
match ma va a sykes animali fantastici e
dove trovarli sai che cos'è animali
fantastici e dove trovarli un film che
uscito il 17 novembre io ho già vissuto
volte tiri fuori sempre tu ce ne sono
due una mia unemia ott io ho questa è la
creatura del film nomi come si chiama la
bellissima questa te la metti addosso e
ti si arrampica no vabbè non ci credo
quanto bello mio bene c'è altra roba
abbiamo la bacchetta di minsk a mander e
questa è mia cara la bacchetta di
all'anno
ecco il dolce proprio la partita molto
bene abbiamo ancora un ultimo regalo che
questo mi sa che per te eh vabbè quanto
grosso questo vale sempre la regola di
mezzo c'è in tutti c'è un fatto di
guardare giochiamo dai basta guardare lo
stesso bastano tutto il mio
così apre non metti le gioca presso il
corso dove cimitile così sopra che poi
compaiono le televisore quindi questa
quale attacchi alla playstation
ac altra roba qua questo è il pacchetto
quello di animali fantastici tra l'altro
visto che c'era guarda c'è questa roba
che lo messi sulla piattaforma io ti
farei la doccia di questi rari gli occhi
è che la vita è una dobbiamo iniziare a
qualche bacia il manuale di istruzioni
qualche pieno di roba da no
[Musica]
ho sbagliato se faccio io faccio con
bravo frazione di strada e james hai
distrutto scusa abbiamo capito ma tu lo
sai come funziona che metti il
personaggio a fare nel gioco e domenica
è compare nel gioco
tu hai chiesto io faccio gli outcome
under bene ok
parliamo di carico e io sono andato ma
cosa serva di lezione centrato c'è gioco
di squadra quando ha capito ma non sto
guardando alla praticamente lui che sono
io vi sono io a una valigia che dove
dentro ci sono gli animali
hai capito questa valigia quella porta
in giro e poi la apre e ci sono gli
animali che escono animali fantastici
si apre questa new york la apre e
scappano tutti e quindi tu devi di
trovare tutti quanti animali che sono a
new york e io sono qui lui quello che ha
la valigia
tu sei la ragazza ma poi e ai tre stessi
capelli invece io coi suoi capelli in un
alto immagini mi immagino i tuoi capelli
non hai visto
ecco questo è scappato dalla valigia
adesso devo andarlo a riprendere e tu mi
dà ecco tu sei questa e tu mi dai una
mano ci siamo io sono quello a destra
allora il nostro obiettivo è quello di
trovarvi liberi mi segue mi vedi tu ecco
ha dentro animale bravo tu devi rompere
questa cosa o un pil a l'ho fatto ho
fatto io lo han dato rivisto
ma vai a prenderlo corrie è in auto
nella nascar ma dentro dove eccolo qua
stiamo sparando fermi ma alla sua età 36
di passando tutta la banca ecco vedi due
era prendilo aia non è a lui che succede
colpa tua
perché scappa sempre ma la faccenda si
fa seria a io costruisco le cose ho
fatto una torta
ho fatto una che una cosa di una
campanella lo so solo allora si sa che
ha capito quanti smettere ha capito poi
anche smettere ha capito poi basta
allora avevo praticamente devi spostare
quest'accordo as posto io risposto io
questa mia ma bravo adesso suona lo sono
bravissimo questo gioco di squadra che
come sia forte come ti entra dentro
ecco qui sapevo che ci può interagire ti
mandano spruzzo d'acqua
aspetta aspetta la zona capace ma è
difficile non ho fatto la sua di magia è
un casino
mai visto dopo easy tu ci sei riuscito
eh vabbè adesso questo se ne va nel
caveau della banca
ci siamo così facendo ma non puoi
scassinare una cassaforte sei un ladro
temo i buoni non ti amo i ladri dobbiamo
riuscire a fare le cose giuste quindi la
cassaforte la pro io visto la rotta non
so come ho fatto le casse queste qui
leve di queste qua questo posso sapere
ma non in queste marroni bravo è questo
ray fare ma sei un killer ma si può si
può cavalcare il vero fenomeno vele
notte rho mi ricordo mai il nome ci
salta sopra cavalchi tocco va al scheme
dobbiamo intercorrente come facciamo a
jacopo come sto facendo questa roba
devo fare qualcosa con questo no questa
è magia
quindi se io rimetto compare di nuovo no
vabbè a invertirli tipo così può essere
perché è solo diventato gigante cosa è
successo quindi si vive
allora io sono diventato grosso
grossissimo un grosso
la chiave dell'ingrandimento permette al
giocatore di inter e più grande e più
piccolo per completare non ficato capi
qua ce l'ha arrivato anch'io colloca un
personaggio sul pannello arancione per
rimpicciolire quindi ti mette
sull'arancione a te scusa non faccio più
ma che festa
si guarda il più bel sederino secondi a
destra perfetto piaceva il quadrato se
adesso siamo giù ci metteremo anni per
capire come si fa una cosa di un gioco
di leggo io non sono capace
il bene nostro maledetto ei tanto
ingegno 6 vedi che questa moda vedi io
ti faccio da ponte ora devi saltare su
di lei come prima laura in quanto non ci
credo ho ricordato premi di nuovo t
punto non è possibile ragazzi e il mio
erede è il mio erede
ma poi tutto tua per me chiude anche tu
chiudi anche sul video ma dubito i
pallini da alessio nati di fan lui
adesso adesso avesse fatto il ponte ci
passi c'è più
dobbiamo mettere questi così qua almeno
in teoria giusto aperta ma perche senza
di te non ce l'avrei mai fatta e te lo
dico gli ha fregato le chiavi perfetto
dobbiamo prenderlo lo prendo la prendo
io lo prendo io lo prendo io non l'ho
preso come ci arrivo lì maledizione ok
devo farmi la scala ok è visto è sceso è
sceso sapevo io se è chiuso nella
cassaforte prima o poi riusciremo a
prenderlo sto maledetto ce l'ha fatta
bene se si chiude dentro veramente me lo
mangio vivo
scommetti che entrava mai detto è ma
tanto entra ero sapevo io ci metto il
cugino quello che avevi stupire visto
cosa verde lo vedi
non è possibile veramente devo seguire
quello che mi dice lui entra sinistra
destra o benedetto la tavola manca
l'ultimo sinistra destra centro guarda
poi che siamo la porta
l'abbiamo trovato il coso come lo
prendiamo
prendi tutti i soldi pretty soldi devo
aprire tutte le cose nel muro ma cos'è
ha schiacciato un muro cosa sto facendo
perché è una guardia mi picchia
maledetto ok no no se perfetto fatto
cosa sta facendo
come l'abbiamo pre c'è adesso per
l'inter ce lo fa montare ma io non sono
capace
tu sei capace io mi aiuti to posso
parlare io quindi ragazzi spero che
questo video vi sia piaciuto è stato e
quanto difficile per allora io il fatto
che quelle croci giocavo da piccolo
solo che probabilmente è molto più
esperto jacopo di me infatti riuscito a
fare delle robe che non sono riuscito a
fare io io ti ringrazio per essere stato
il mio confratello in questa grandissima
impresa batte il pugno
ahi ahi noi bicchiere avere gatti
svegliare questo video vi sia piaciuto
l'aggiornamento è mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook facendo a cavalieri
facebook e come notata una descrizione
non su jacopo una descrizione si
discrete vi ci vediamo al prossimo video
belle belle belle ragazze possiamo
tacere è impazzito alla fine fai un
saluto la videocamera fa tutto quello
che dici adesso vai a conquistare il
mondo
[Musica]